and then another part of this whole
Brazil this recent UFO crash
quote-unquote crash in Brazil is this
thing right here the part of the map on
if you go on Google Maps and you go to
this exact spot people are claiming that
for some reason this part of the map
it's completely whited out and I mean
it's like the shape of a flying saucer
in a movie and here's what's funny but
why is that part
why is it blacked out why is it white it
out like that one of the guys actually
said that it's a Sun glint but what's
interesting is a shiny roof it's being
reflected but you could see there's kind
of a flare no it looks to me like it was
cut out of there somehow like it's been
digitally yeah yeah literally yeah
because of the pixelation if it was a
Sun I mean if it was like a a lens flare
or a reflection from a bright shiny roof
or something it would be kind of like
those upper edges would be like a kind
of a blurred edge not a pixelated edge
with a shadow around looking like it was
cut literally that's Google Maps this is
Google Earth right here same thing yeah
no is Earth you can see more top where
they're saying that the crash is that
this is exactly where they're saying the
crash was at yeah right in for Frago so
and the outside of Rio yeah right
outside of Rio yeah so all right [ __ ] to
explain idea well I'll tell you what's
kind of funny you know if you look at
the shape of that cut you look at the
shape of the one that the pilot in the
Navy is chasing they look very similar
very similar to that how do we see what
the pilot in the Navy oh oh in the video
the video in those videos that were
really felt an incorrect croak I and it
looks like a kind of like a top but it
looks like a UFO a saucer shape but it's
got that odd peculiar something in the
middle of it bump yeah that's super
strange and is this I don't know if this
has been seen anywhere else on Google
Maps oh they live like this how did they
talk about this they talk about this in
great detail but again because they
don't really have a whole lot to look at
it or talk to you who is talking about
it again this was somebody on YouTube
pull this up they the I'll send you the
link to it oh yeah that basically just
kind of outlines
what they thinks going on because they
actually at some point in the Instagram
I'm looking at looks like they launch
rockets and you hear them going off in
the background again it's you know
Brazil is very militant in their
thinking you know the White House has
actually missiles and buildings around
them so if an aircraft tried to crash
into it they could not get thing out of
the sky hmm I don't see why the
Brazilians wouldn't have something
similar to that especially because we
work with the Brazilians a lot we trust
them they're there I mean listen the
other day that we're all on the same
team yeah it's kind of [ __ ] up to
think that if a UFO actually crashed in
Brazil the first thing human beings do
is start [ __ ] shooting it I wouldn't
put it past listen with this whole plan
we are [ __ ] barbarians look at the
coronavirus look how many people are
buying into the whole mask thing I know
those come people that hate me for
saying that but I'm yeah I got bad news
for you all that does is prevent you
from giving it doesn't prevent you from
getting it coming through your eyes
right right it prevents you from from
like if you call for you sneeze it keeps
particles and whatever germs away from
people around you and again looking at
this it was opposed to be 2.2 million
people that were gonna be killed and I
think we're and I'm sure in looking at
some of the information I've seen on the
virus
I actually saw where Pennsylvania the
hospital there had talked to hundred
people that they said it that had died
from corona virus didn't so I'm sure
there's some skewed numbers out there I
see that some of the hospitals are
getting subsidized by the federal
government if they have had a lot of
coronavirus patients there yeah I read
that somewhere too in like Mexico that
they're getting paid well know everyone
every hospital is getting paid if you if
you have a death from coronavirus you
make it's something to be effective like
thirty thousand dollars versus a regular
death is like eight thousand Wow
so from with if someone's sick and in
hospital reports that as a CO vyd they
get thirty like ten times the amount of
money they would have normally get from
the government and that's kind of skewed
nobody knows nobody really knows any of
these ninety thousand people have died
I'm listen I don't want you know one
person to die I think when you start
going back and looking at it also to the
large percentage of these are these
retirement facilities
so there's currently a 1.6 million cases
in the US and today as of what is
today's memorial day the 22nd 2015 600
deaths total so almost 100,000 and like
I say I don't want to see anybody job it
certainly is a 2.2 million people yeah
right now that came out and again most
of the people that are dying are people
who have had high blood pressure they
suffer from all kinds of right well
issues the average age of death from
this is higher than the average age of
mortality in the u.s. period absolutely
absolutely we first broke out I went to
the CDC and it was I was looking at at
influenza last year and I showed 34,000
people died and about 900,000 people
were at the hospital right at this point
I think we were just approaching on the
on this side of the bay with with the
virus about about 30 or 35 thousand but
at the time it room said listen it's no
different than what was taking place
last year and oh by the way if you're
not practicing clean hygiene by washing
your hands
yeah well I went to the gym the other
day and I laughs peace when I walk
inside the guy wanted to take my
temperature and I said Bob let me ask
you guys how many times you've had a
fever felt like one of the Jim I don't
wanna get out of my house I said exactly
he goes listen it's just we're going
through the stages we have a lot of
elderly people also that under under the
sneaker program I think it's called blue
sneakers for the elderly what is it
silver sneakers and they are allowed to
you know come into the gym and these are
these are much older people and I would
probably say okay anybody at that age
could be at risk but if you didn't be in
there I wouldn't say you listen again if
you don't feel good don't come in right
feel fine come on down to the gym and
train let's get back to where it was
right right right I mean there's a
problem the problem is people don't like
to follow that people's rules and you
know at the end of the day it's these
private businesses if they want to take
your temperature
or if they want you to wear a mask they
have the right to [ __ ] tell you to do
that or go to go to another gym if you
don't want to do it absolutely people
just want to like [ __ ] and complain
like it's my constitutional right to
come into your gym or to shop at your
store no it's not it's someone's
business most private business like I
said man I get it at the end of the day
if you're a risk yeah everybody needs to
keep that in mind yeah
for sure but I get at the same time
there's something else that's going on
because as these events kind of unfold
in the bigger picture what is really
going on I mean you know you look at
like I say the skinwalker ranch and how
all of a sudden amazing this place has
become and they're down you know you go
to ancient aliens now on the History
Channel and they've got every guy in the
world on there who's talking about Machu
Picchu and T Kapoor and all the
different places in Peru they just found
now found some skulls out there that
don't have a Sagittarius line which
separates the center of the skull and
they initially said that what they do is
the inhabitants of this location and
they're going back probably five to six
thousand years ago would actually do a
thing called binding and they would tie
the head so that the skull became long
and he the the professor who was
teaching the class was like well why
were they doing that they just didn't do
that one day because they woke up and
felt like hey we want to tie our kids
heads make him/her long like this he
said there were there had there had been
extraterrestrials there that had this
elongated skull and that they found
these skulls these skulls were 40%
heavier
25% bigger than a regular skull and had
no such terse line that went down the
center of the skull and he really he oh
oh and he goes it also didn't have any
micro Condrey at DNA because everything
on the planet has that and again I'm
like well why isn't this big news where
is the awe the shock and awe over these
events and these stories I mean are we
so used to it now because we've seen
every type of you know sci-fi show on TV
from Star Trek nobody believes anymore
the thing the thing is there's there's
scientists out there and researchers who
have had their research sort of
established already and when new
information or new discoveries come out
these people want to discredit it
because their egos are attached to their
discoveries and to what to what is
already accepted sure so if you've
devoted your life to one to one ideology
to one scientific ideology and someone
else comes in 20 years later and says no
you guys are missing something
then it's sad that their ego kind of
gets attached to it and they just want
to like discredit that person or say oh
that's a pseudo scientist oh yeah and I
think I think that's
obviously that's a great point because I
see that going on a lot like if you look
at the Great Sphinx in Egypt and they
talk about how old the Sphinx is and a
geologist actually came out and said no
it's actually much older than that they
said why is that he said because what
we're looking at was done with water not
wind this was a rosin on the side of the
actual space right and he came down and
said well when it's water erosion it
goes one way and when it's wind erosion
it runs actually lateral to the to the
ground and he said that this isn't this
was done by water and so if you took the
planet and kind of reverse wobble it
they could go back almost 10,000 years
to when that area was extremely wet
mm-hmm and he believes that's when the
[ __ ] was actually put up was put up
before the Egyptians were there the
Egyptians kind of came into it right of
the fact right so the same same thing
with mantra mantra mantra Picchu
absolutely in Peru absolutely they say
that the people there basically came
there and just moved in they didn't
create it because there's no possible
way humans it would take like thirty
thousand three thousand humans to carry
one of those I don't know how many
people they said it would take but
basically those things are tens 10 tons
20 ton bricks and I thought they came
from to Mountain to mountain tops away
you know were they trying to convince me
they dragged them you know 3,000 miles
you think I see the other mountaintop
that came from but they dragged them
that far when I had other guys say well
the you know the Egyptians used rope and
they used these logs and I'm like who
was making the rope mmm-hmm how long was
that rope was it really that strong like
if you know 3,000 men could pull on it
and yeah come on man really yeah
there's something bigger going on you
look at look at how much they talk today
and they really associate the pyramids
with astronauts look at the Mayans the
Mayans had a calendar a 30 day calendar
we'd liked it so much that we adopted
that calendar and the interesting thing
is that the Mayans accounted for the
wobble that the earth has yeah I mean
how do you do that how do you understand
there's a wobble when you don't get off
the planet so there there's something
else that's going on why are there why
their pyramids there's more pyramids in
South America than all of Egypt there's
about 10,000 pyramids to South America
how did and the South America had no
contact with Egypt how did they know to
make that same type of building the same
design the same design you know using I
mean whether this was to generate power
or to communicate or it was set up as a
hey this is the time of year that we
were in a plant wheat you know the
summer solstice is here and marks those
because many of the buildings do mark
those and you know the summer solstice
when it's time to plant when it's not
time to wet season and yet everyone
wants to take it off at these savages
out here that have these you know bows
and arrows and rocks they chipped at it
put these things up
[Laughter]